live chair thank you very much brother
good afternoon welcome to the southeast
area planning committee meeting on
Wednesday the 8th of July two thousand
twenty my name is councillor Michael
Hill and I'm vice chairman of this
committee deputizing for the chairmen
councillor richard Dueck this meeting is
held under the new cold covered
regulations which came into effect on
April 4th in response to the covert 19
situation there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
including our new working practices
which have been implemented due to the
pandemic and the ethic work for this
meeting first of all please can I ask
everyone present at this meeting to
ensure their microphones remain muted
and your video feed is off we're not
addressing the committee this will
reduce background noises and avoid
unintentional disturbances this meeting
will be hosted remotely via conferencing
software which allows member of the
public to visually attend the meeting
whilst being able to protect themselves
and others and observe the government's
lockdown measures we will not encounter
any glitches this afternoon so everyone
will bear with us as we get used to this
new way of working we are streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function for the
meeting to indicate you wish to speak I
will then invite you to appropriate our
members a reminder that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or you have
to leave the room meeting the chat
function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose members
the process this afternoon will
obviously be different and by some items
are may invite each member to speak in
term therefore I encourage all members
to keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and not speak over
each other when speaking and referring
to the agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
could
I ensure that everybody is directly
connected to the power supply so nobody
drops out to you to shorty check battery
life and last if members need to leave
the meeting at any point please make
this known and use the chat function to
signify that you need to leave the
meeting now my ass the officers taking
part in the reason to introduce
themselves start with this delay good
afternoon members I'm Matthew Lee and
I'm lead specialist place here at Malden
district council Thank You chairman
anybody else just good afternoon chair
and members my name is Michael Johnson
I'm the lead specialist development
management thank you good afternoon i'm
louise staple Hurst and I'm a specialist
in development management thank you
next one please good afternoon members
I'm Anna Keene I'm a senior caseworker
at development management thank you and
of course burners here as well thank you
thank you chairman and I would call your
names alphabetically members councillor
Basinger good afternoon and I'm the
president
Thank You councillor Beal present good
afternoon everybody
councillor Belle counselor Belle she
sent apologies burner Thank You
councillor boys present councillor chana
good afternoon everyone
yes I'm present Thank You councillor
felucca present Thank You councillor
hung its president Chris castor Hall
castor Hall I know she's present
yeah you can see Thank You counselor
skiing good afternoon
Thank You counselor stamp present burner
members afternoon thank you could those
members in attendance please introduce
themselves now Thank You councillor
karlie Mays Moulton North thank you good
afternoon and welcome councillor Chrissy
Morris thank you very much Thank You
chairman we've received apologies for
absence from councillor doing and
councillor pal okay
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of June it is recommended the minutes of
the meeting held on the 8th of June on
to 2020 found at pages 7 to 14 or
approved at a true and accurate record I
so move if you wish to second that
motion please turn on your video I'll
make your microphone and state your name
now repeater second to thank you
counselor Kenna
declarations of interest disclose the
existence and nature of any disciplinary
interests or other pecuniary interests
or non-pecuniary interests relating to
license of business on the agenda have
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive the code of conduct members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
they camera where should the need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
any interest to clear please use the
chat function they are to indicate and
they will write you to speak German
constitutes Lucca and Council of China
would like to speak okay who's first
cast Lucca and how yeah thank you
chairman with regards to agenda items 5
9 and 10 I know the applicants and their
hang on a better star game with regards
to agenda items
five 10 and 17 I know the applicants
done non-pecuniary and with regards to
agenda item 9 pecuniary interest
Chairman I won't be taking any part my
wife and I are actually the applicants
thank you
Thank You chairman wish to declare
number carry interesting that I'm also a
member of Essex County Council and of
course that body is consulted on matters
to do with highways accesses and any
other matters under their remit that
they should be consulted on I'll declare
an interest on agenda item number 5 I
know the applicant and agenda item
number 9 of course I know Council of
Luke well he's mr. Fluker putting the
application on to opportunity we all
need to declare an interest that we know
councillor felucca so I guess we all
have to declare that that mr. Smith is
patent it's counselor White's all right
okay yes exactly
well I wish to declare an interest in
item 5 counselor why it's a fellow
counselor
she lives in my ward and she also lives
in the farm that my grandfather owned
when I was about 12 an interest in
number 9 as that's the feluccas
counselor and counselor 10 counsel voice
as a fellow counsel yes yes hello I do
as well I obviously know counselor
felucca and I know counselor white and I
know count to the hull so that's that's
my nan de Kooning interest thank you
very much and chairman can we can we
hope that as everybody knows the
counselor or do we all have to say it we
move now to plan the application 2000 3
4 5 / ful land adjacent house mrs. chase
mainland in a moment I will call the
Omni offices to present this item
remembers a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please use this make
this be unknown by using the chat
function within this meeting but I will
then come to you in turn please keep
your points appearance except Lee
mistake for us please present the
reports Thank You chairman
the application seeks to very
conditioned to an dates of previously
approved permission for the change of
use of land to equestrian and the
construction of a building to be used
for storage of agricultural most agree
cultural machinery and the stabling of
horses condition 2 relates to the
approved plans and condition 8 relates
to details of fowl drainage to be
submitted to the council the amendments
under this application are that the
building will be 0.5 meters deeper and T
metres wider and will have slightly
smaller windows and also no fowl
drainage is proposed this is the
location plan showing the site outlined
in red
this shows the previously approved block
plan and the building shown here and
here the building posed under this
application slightly slightly larger the
previously approved floor plans and the
proposed floor plans showing the
slightly larger building the approved
and proposed front and side elevations
and showing these slight changes in
fenestration and again the approved and
proposed rear and side elevations these
photographs show the view towards the
site through the access and the view
northeast towards where the building
would be positioned and the view towards
an orchard house owned by the applicants
used within the site and south of the
site and the view of the driveway for
the Apple Store which was approved under
a 2018 application which is to the south
of the site overall the amendments to
this application are considered to be
acceptable and therefore the application
is recommended for approval Thank You
chairman Thank You mr. West
I love the council public participation
scheme we have received one submission
from the applicant in line with the
public participation scheme I've
reviewed the submission and now we'll
read it out allocating 2 minutes only
for the reading of the submission in
accordance with the scheme
the mission is from mr. and mrs. Patton
the applicants dear members of the
committee we would like to thank the
members of the committee for granting
the original application for this bomb
we have asked a very condition of the
conditions to plans as the original make
measurements used were taken from the
previous owner of the building which we
use for the application the balance
shape and design is identical to that
already granted permission but it is
slightly larger it was suggested that we
build it anyway as probably no one would
check but we did didn't think that there
was right to do so we have put in for a
variation of the condition as suggested
by the officers and there is a slight
alteration to the size we have asked to
remove the condition 8 as we already
have permission for a toilet in the
Apple Store and don't need another one
we hope that you can support this Thank
You mr. mrs. Kenny Patton chairman may
refer to other officers being before
finally being moved there's any one
officer wouldn't make another comment no
recommendation the Planning Act of 2000
three four five ful 9tj doghouse niches
chase moment be approved job conditions
as detailed in Section rating report if
any member wishes to second this motion
please turn on your video I move your
microphone the state your name now I'm
happy to second that chairman cancer
stamp
thank you can cancer stem thank you and
I invite members to make any comments on
the report the recommendation chairman
and well no member has indicated their
wish to speak and you council staff the
seconded the
application so if you want to go
straight to the boat then that's
entirely down to the committee if nobody
else's any comments did second it can I
ask one question yes I was very
interested with the applicants comment
about they were told to build it anyway
just wanted to know who actually told
them to build it anyway because I was
really pleased that they had the decency
to bring it back to the council rather
than just do as they're like whether it
be cancer or not is immaterial to me
they should be thanked for actually
bringing it back to the council I'm not
well as members know normally to
approved conditions because I think they
were made for a reason but you know this
has been explained fully they've already
got a toilet in another building they
don't need a toilet I can't see any
issue with it chairman and thank you
they must be right we'll move to the
vote then please burner Thank You
chairman I will take your names enough
special order and it's four against
abstain so before we do that we didn't
get an answer to council stamps question
about who told them that they could
build it anyway until we asked them in
private when the meetings finished is
that clear fair enough
consular Basinger approve a bill
approved councilor boys abstain chana
prove whose um council ahem
please Oh
Thank You castle Erskine's approve as
the stamp thank you
that's eight for one abstention
thank you thank you burner we move now
to again to item six planning action 20
double O 3 6 0 ful the bank house 10
Station Road South mr. found on pages 27
to 44 please note that as a members
update in relation to this application
has also been circulated prior to
meeting has everyone received that in a
moment I will call the officers to plant
the item members a reminder that if you
wish to speak on this item please make
this known using the chat function
within this meeting I will then come you
to you in turn please keep your points
clear and succulent such a whoever is
been ashamed
yes hull this application seeks to
change the use of the site to
residential and the demolition of part
of the rear wing and a first-floor
extension to create five flats the
previous application at the site has
approved four flats and an application
before that repeat refused permission
for for larger flats I'll speak about
these applications in more detail
throughout the presentation as mentioned
the start date which includes the
correct site map the tree consultant
response and which dates no objections
and also stating the agent has confirmed
the applicant is willing to sign a legal
agreement in relation to rams which is
the second reason for a few so this is
the location plan showing the site this
is the exist
ding site plan and the proposed layout
the amenity space has been shown to the
north of the site's this is a private
garden area of 20 square meters which
will be used in relation to this
two-bedroom flats and a communal area
here measuring 42 square meters which
would be used for the other three
one-bedroom flats and one two-bedroom
flat four flats would be required by the
design guide to have a total amenity
space of hundred square meters and
therefore the 42 square meters proposed
would be a significant shortfall it is
noted that shortfall was accepted under
the previous approved application
however an additional flat has now been
proposed and no more I mean that he
space provided these are the existing
elevations of the building are the
proposed elevations showing the
first-floor extension here and this part
to the rear these are the existing floor
plans please note that this first floor
area and these have been labeled as
bedrooms but the agent has confirmed
that whilst it appears they may have
been built as bedrooms internally there
are name plaques on each door which
appear to show that its last use was as
a solicitor's office due to the age of
the building there isn't any other
planning history to dispute this and
therefore the change of use has been
assessed as though the building has an
office use and this is stated in Section
3 point 1 point 11 of the officer report
so these are the proposed and ground
floor plan and first floor plan so this
is one of the flats with the upstairs
living area and this is the second flat
down here third flat at the school level
here for fourth flat at ground floor
level here and they were approved under
the previous application and then this
first floor two-bedroom flat shaded is
the
proposed under this application so this
shows the previous approved scheme the
fifth trap wasn't included under this
application the level of amenity space
proposed under this proposed under the
approved application and the proposed
application has not increased even
though an additional two-bedroom flat is
proposed you can see it here which is
the same layout as the current
application this is the previously
refused scheme there was an amenity area
here of 64 square meters provided and
between three two-bedroom flats and one
one-bedroom flats and this application
was refused as there wouldn't have been
enough amenity space here are some
photos showing the front of the building
on the site here and the view to the
west the view to the east and the view
along the access to the rear of the site
at the view towards the western boundary
of the site and the turning area the
rear of the building here and the view
Southwest toward the access there's a
view looking north and this is where the
amenity space would go here the private
amenity space and the communal saw over
here and then also the parking area
would be here as well
overall whilst the previous application
approved a shortfall in amenity space a
further two bedroom flat has now been
proposed and no additional amenity space
and therefore the shortfall would be
exacerbated which would harm the living
conditions of the future occupiers
furthermore in the absence of a signed
legal agreement to secure mitigation in
relation to rands this would result in
the proposal being unacceptable and is
therefore recommended for a feasel thank
you chairman thank you very much out of
the council public participation scheme
we have received one submission from the
applicant in line with public
participation scheme I have reviewed the
submission and will now read it out
allocating 2 minutes only for the
reading the submission in accordance
with the scheme submission is from Ellis
Wiseman the applicant
an opportunity to restate an attractive
building which will enhance the High
Street Conservation Area and the setting
of to commedia expensive listed
buildings namely some letters Church and
homey stone this application allows the
entire building to be completed as one
coherent development rather than leave
were an important section the building
unresolved while scheme does not meet
the precise square meter each required
for amenity space provision providing
the building with walking distance of
the towns playing fields playground
sports car can be served footpaths and
the town streets our immediate is the
mold district camp counselor meeting
requirements would be 25 square meters
for apartment the space available is 111
square meters thus the 11% shortfall I
don't understand that this scheme will
revoke resolve the refuse and recycling
storage provision neatly and securely
whilst providing a parking space for
each unit the applicant has the team of
builders waiting to come in to the
projects and would hope the committee
can see the importance of commencing and
completing this additional flat at the
same time as the four previously
approved apartments does any other
officer want to comment before I move on
no cheering all right the recommendation
is set up with the fort is as follows
that the planning application remained
Houston Station Road South needs to be
refused for the reasons as detailed in
section 8 of the report if any member
wishes to second that motion please turn
your video I'm out your microphone and
state your name now
Oh buddy no chairman sorry I'll second
it
okay I now move to my comments on the
report well honor who is indicate to
speak yeah Casa de Luca would like to
speak German
Thank You chairman I speak as one of the
board members for South Minister and
German I'd like to direct the members
attention to page 29 of the morgen
district design guide and in particular
policy Co 7 which deals with residential
outdoor amenity space and and having
read that I'm just a bit confused as the
officers recommendation because it says
quite clearly that usable outdoor means
to space could be in the form of private
communal Gardens balconies children's
play areas allotments or public spaces
so chairman for the for the benefit
those that have never been to South Main
store or know this area particularly
well he's directly opposite the entrance
to the king george v playing fields
which i've got what it's just down the
road I can say bran not in this thing so
it's very very close to king george v
which has got which has got playground
equipment and everything else there and
and it also chairman it's it's very
important that with these flatting time
accommodations where we look closely
nearby and we look at Cherry Orchard we
look at tanta shores none of them
actually meet these design requirements
which I find quite strange albeit that
they were apologised that they were they
were built before the LDP was approved
so and the other thing is Germany it
also says on the policy Co 7 that
depending on the scale of the
development and the quality and quantity
of existing provisions in the wider area
it may be necessary to incorporate an
element of outdoor amenity space so the
actual policy says it it may be
necessary may be necessary chairman to
include this outdoor community area it
only maybe and tomato and because you've
got the the public playing field
by that actually does tend to counter
that so Germany in summary since the
bank closed this was the old Barclays
Bank building it's been empty for many
many years as Lister did operate from
one part of it and through that period
of time chairman it has deteriorated an
enormous Lee and it's been coming it's
becoming now something of an eyesore
which is in a residential area and I
continue you know I do get complaints
from neighbors nearby asking what's
going to happen to it
I think the last time it came to this
committee it was for a restaurant take
away and that was refused
so chairman in some way there you know
this is an opportunity to provide some
much-needed threated accommodation for
the village South Minster parish
councils support the application the
conservation officer has no objection
and it is in a very nice part of the
village there's no objections from
highways no letters of objections are
being received and it's a matter of
choice really for future residents
whether or not they want to occupy these
properties knowing that it doesn't have
a huge amount of community space so
terminal lack of een amenity space as
described by offices and still meets the
criteria of the design guide Co 7 and
that said chairman contrary to the
officers recommendation and subject to
an assigned 106 agreement with regards
to blams I'd propose chairman that we we
actually approve this recommend we
approve this application thank you Thank
You councillor bill would you like to
speak yes please I support is my mic on
sorry yes yes I totally support the use
of this building for the purpose stated
we've already turned it down as a
restaurant etc and there aren't many
other users that it can be put to so I
think this is the best option we've got
to see this building is used and so it
doesn't fall into disrepair there is a
need for flats in South Minster we've
got west allis estate coming online
shortly and that has certainly shown a
lot of interest to local South Minister
people too
look for flats so I think that there
won't be any problem about the usage of
it at the end of the day but if it's
just going to be turned down because of
lack of amenity space and there doesn't
seem to be other option I do think that
this should be approved Chairman castor
stamp would like to speak Thank You
chairman just for the benefit of any of
the members that don't know the area
well as well as what everybody else
seems to and have clarifications from
the offices that the previous planning
application was approved so they've
already got planning permission to build
for that I'll convert it to flats this
is only because they want to squeeze an
additional morning chairman is that
correct yes so they have and I'll just
put the presentation up again easier to
explain so they have permission for
these these flat for flats in this area
here and upstairs here so it's just this
shaded area because that this wasn't
within the applicants ownership at the
time of the previous application so all
this sort of in white does have
permission it's just the this additional
flat is now proposed as it's been stated
they haven't increased the level of
amenity space Thank You chairman I just
think it's really important that you
know this is that same fact of dipping
into the LDP dipping into what other
policies we've got SPD's and dipping out
when it suits us and my take on board
what councillor Fluker has just said um
but I'm actually airing towards
supporting the officers recommendation
on this one but thank you chairman Thank
You Louise do you want to come back on
the point just about the manatee space
and then if necessary I'll pick up the
point about the design guide and
overarching principle if you yeah that's
fine and through chairman and so in
relation to the level of amenity space
provided it is noted what members have
said about their beings or playing field
being in a rural area in places where
future occupiers could walk and this and
this may justify a minor shortfall in
amenity space provision and but it's not
considered that that would justify that
the level that has been provided so not
not providing any additional amenity
space for the additional flats so forty
two square meters would be provided and
a hundred square meters would need to be
provided according to the design guide
and it's considered that that level of
shortfall is significant and would harm
median teacher occupiers and quality of
living and thank you chairman thank you
thank chairman in relation to section 6
Co 6 their councillor felucca referenced
in the design guide that section is in
relation to more strategic placemaking
and it also talks about providing sports
and community facilities and things like
that it's not a section in relation to
specifically in relation to on-site
provision for a single development or
conversion such as this as the officer's
report explains and as members ability
queried and his mistake was just litter
ated the development already has
permission for flats and this is an
increase development by providing
additional flat officers consider the
two-bedroom flats a potential to be
family accommodation have children
living in them and private amenity space
or usable means space at least on site
is essential for such developments the
current proposal that has permission
does have a less amount of amenities by
also a similar manner of new space but
has less properties obviously that's a
material difference and as officers we
consider the additional flat which is a
family accommodation would result in an
unacceptable impact on the future
occupies due to me into space because it
is conchita policy and as one thing I
just like to flag up that council of
Lucas reference to
co6 is about open spaces in more place
making love than applications such as
this and we have won appeals on similar
NH because generally if you've got a
small child you wouldn't let it go to a
play area away from the site without
being watched being viewed and therefore
it's unlikely to be constant or an
active action Thank You chairman thank
you yes chairman cast of Luke would like
to come back ok yep so Jeff and I was
just flicking between you and the design
guide so I think that mr. Lee was
speaking about he was talking about
policy co6 I was actually talking about
Co 7 which talks about was residential
outdoor amenity and I've just gone
through we've gone through it again and
I've read it all and it doesn't say
anything about strategic sites on page
29 in fact it alludes to flatted
developments so I sort of don't quite
get that you know normally mr. Lee is
right but I am reading page 29 and page
29 looks pretty clear to me it seems to
cover all development um not just
strategic ones I mean I'll just flick
through to the front page just in case
after all these years I've missed
something but no term and I'm reading
the full word that was that was written
by councilor channel in it and yeah I
can't see where it says that applies
only to this document only applies to
strategic sites so I'm not I stand by my
comments thank you sorry counsel I miss
her I thought you stated co6
as what you were referencing which is
open spaces and which identifies things
such as wider reliance Co 7 is about
residential amenity space and has like
an adequate amount of Manatee space has
been finding 3h welling the oval size
the guard and it's in proportion with
the type of dwelling and the character
of the area the minimum standard set
design guides are achieved for houses of
three bedroom classes hundred meters
squared per once to bed unit so one
stupid unit is 50 meters flats is 25
meters squared the external amenity
space is has not been compromised by the
location two parking areas so see this
points weren't the ones you read out
earlier so that's what's just confused
me but I must have got myself wrong I
apologize
Thank You chairman sorry chairman I'm
still reading this and yeah I mean mr.
Lee's right Co seven it does go on to
say that makes sure that but that's es6
design guide and what I'm referring to
is the narrative which is in the modern
district design guide and it says in
there quite clearly it may be necessary
so it's not actually fixed in stone this
it says it may be necessary to provide
these facilities if there aren't any any
nearby so I'm still just a little bit
confused but this is a typical
subjective comment that we get in these
documents and they're open to
interpretation chairman so you know
there's a proposal on the table which I
think's been seconded and and I'd ask
that you put the question chairman thank
you first let's you - sorry it took the
officers recommendation fast
okay the officers recommendation is
refused can you take a vote please burn
up thank you sorry is everybody happy
with that but I go ahead and take a vote
now so just for clarity was his second
deed of yes both councilor Java
challenge second recommendation okay in
alphabetical order and state for against
abstain councillor Basinger for the
officers recommendation of refusal kazna
Basinger there I'm against the officers
recomendation Thank You counsel appeal
against sorry counselor boys of stein
pants no Fluker against come against
asthma halt
oh sorry counselor Skeens sorry abstain
as a stamp and I'm for the officers
recommendation burner so generous I
haven't been off oh sorry counselor
channa it's just I'd apologies in
Doncaster do it I missed you
castor chana for the officer
recommendation thank you very much so
that's two for the officers
recommendation for against and two
abstentions
yes yes you don't speak the officer
recommendation I would need reasons for
approval please cast a fluke certainly
Germany accords with policy Co 7 and the
Morton district design guard
chairman thank you that wasn't what was
by chance of lucrative and I don't think
a safe position just to make such a
categorical statement what I would say
is that counsel fluke earlier vocalized
that he considered due to the close
proximity to other open space and other
was facilities that it wasn't a
detrimental impact is what I would say
it was what was debated earlier rather
than they definitely complies with the
policy Thank You chairman chairman I'm
grateful for mr. Lee's coming I was just
putting that in summary really by
applying Co 7 and the nearby amenity
space so I'm going forward to mr. Lee
for that
Thank You chairman okay thank you
chairman in alphabetical order again for
against
staying to approve country to the
officers recommendation counselor
passenger for Sabeel or sorry burn after
clarity that was to prove subject to the
completion of section 106 yes yeah yeah
yeah cancel appeal or Thank You
counselor boys abstain how's channa
abstaining
[Music]
Katsav Luka for for us know how sorry
counselor Skeens abstain and stamp
against members that's for for the
recommendation one against and three
abstentions
so that's carried okay thank you very
much we move on to land 48 yes you're
muted Berluti yes apologies and I was
just making sure that council Hall was
back in the meeting she is now back in
thank you very much it right okay thank
you
we move on to now to application 2003
7/5 ful land rear of out in 48 station
or a Burnham on crouch found on pages 45
to 70 Eric please note that members
update is in relation to this
application has also been circulated
prior to a meeting in a moment call I
will call the officer to present this
ice and members a reminder that if he
wish to speak on the sites and please
make known using the chat function
within this meeting I will then come to
you in turn please keep your points
clear and concise can we have the
officer printed presenting their
application please
Thank You chairman Michael Johnson these
specialists present in this application
on behalf of the case officer I'll just
share my screen
Thank You chairman now this application
proposes the change of use from Class B
1 and B 2 to Class C 3 the proposal is a
demolition of the existing dilapidated
industrial building an erection of four
new residential dwelling houses and
salary development and landscaping so I
will I will take you through the
presentation slides so here we have the
site outlined rather Tesco's to the
south we have the properties along
Station Road to the west and then we
have all close to our East and here we
have the site plan in more detail the
site is no point two hectares in sight
just to point out to members here that
this is the existing dilapidated
industrial building and b-1b to reduce
class here just a more topographical
site and here we have the proposed site
plan and I'll just as I'm going through
the slides just point out some of the
fundamental difference from the report
members are aware that the previous
scheme comprised 5 dwellings and that
was refused the reason for refusal are
set out in the report this scheme
proposes to address the reasons for
refusal the scheme has been reduced from
five units to four units so just point
it out here we have two three bedroom
detached dwellings and then we have a
pair of semis comprised in two bedrooms
we have the access Drive which is
existing to the south of the dwellings
we have a green open space and then we
have the grog gardens to the north some
of the fundamental different
again was that there was an additional
dwelling to the eastern boundary a
detached dwelling which was included in
the reasons for refusal previously of
poor design and also his proximity to
the boundary the other reasons for
refusal are going to set out in the
report was that the building the
development comprised an RD crammed form
of development no space in in between
the buildings a large expanse of
hard-surfaced area and considered
therefore unsuitable in this case we can
see there clear reasons here in terms of
the cramped form of development
[Music]
apologies I just heard a sound we can
see the gaps in between the building to
provide the spacings as addressing the
previous reason for refusal in between
those gaps we have some parking spaces
too aligned to the detached dwellings
and then to the front of the pair of
semies we also have two and then we also
have another two on the corresponding
sides the scheme there provides eight
parking spaces okay so moving through
again we have the proposed drainage
strategy this slide has been included
because lack of a sufficient drainage
strategy was part of the reason for
refusal on the previous scheme so this
sets out the particular areas of the
drainage scheme which members might find
useful the sort of crossed hatch type
area is the permeable paving we also
have the storage areas here in in red
and the various other lines comprise the
existing combined sewer new foul syrup
new fowl rising main existing surface
water sewer surface water rise in main
and the arrow along the access drives
just shows us the poverty of the site
which leads downwards towards the road
showing the the direction of any surface
water flow
these are the existing elevations of the
existing b1 b2 building single-story
development in the northwest corner are
seen on the location plan and here we
have the detailed elevations and plans
of the proposed detached dwellings again
just to point out here that the these
dwellings have been changed and designed
to create a form which is more condensed
it's got hips bruise to the Front's
there for compacting the development and
decrease in this overall mass as
compared to the previous scheme the
layout we can see there three bedrooms
on the first floor living room kitchen
diner on the ground floor this slide
shows the pair of semies two-bedroom
dwellings again two bedrooms on the
first floor living diner arrangement on
the ground floor to the right here we
can see the psycho stores all the units
are provided with they're secured and
covered cycle stores within there there
curtilage so whoever proposed street
scene the proposed street scene as can
seen from the bottom is a cross-section
taken through the site where the site
joins a boundary with the Tesco store
you can see the development there
members can probably also see the dotted
line indicating the scale of the
previous schemes which was in the form
of two pairs of semi and the single
detached
building which was plot five adjacent to
the Blackwall Road development we can
see the slight topic of the
topographical gradient leading down
towards Station Road
and again this is just showing the
previously refused scheme seen the sort
of dense nature of the development
restricted gaps through a smaller open
space area to the south the extent of
hard standing and also there sufficient
details of the training strategy was not
produced with this particular scheme
again just showing it in elevation so we
can see that the the design form again
less compact more Square and sort of
block EULA okay impacting on the overall
spaciousness that of well compared to
the current scheme and also we can see
in relationship to the scale of the
existing dwellings on the site now
they've taken through the photographs
access to the site the core closed over
to the east the third slide that's
showing a view sort of North West we can
see part of the Tesco's carpark there
and the flank elevation of one four
eight fourth picture the Tesco store its
relationship with the boundary on here
there's a series of photographs panning
around the site so we can see its its
nature the second at the top you can see
the rear of Tesco's bottom left-hand
corner we can see the existing
commercial building and to the right of
two angles again just panning around the
site then in the bottom left-hand corner
we can see a view from within the site
looking toward Station Road again we can
see part side and flank of number one
four eight Station Road and on the other
side we can see the corresponding
elevation to world Blackwall close
again just to give members of feel due
to the various boundaries thank you so
thank you I was just so remembers I'm
just fiddling around with the
technologies it might be useful if I
probably just actually leave the
location plan on the screen just for
your just go back to that one that's
probably the site plan is probably
probably quite useful for yourselves so
as per the officers recommendation this
scheme is recommended for approval his
officers view that the scheme addresses
the reasons for refusal the members
update shows that outstanding matters
particularly in terms of the the
unilateral undertaken has been assigned
by the applicant Essex highways have no
objections to this scheme subject to
conditions and as such the scheme is
recommended for refusal Thank You
chairman thank you very much this scheme
we have received two submissions while
from ejector and one from the applicant
in line with the public participation
scheme
I've reviewed the submission and will
now read out allocated two minutes only
for a reading of the submission and a
call each submission according with the
scheme submission one from David house
and ejector brief response
I live at free brick will close not
brick will present but we're standing
mine and other affected residents
previous objection to development but
I'd point out the three designated late
ec2 is on land not as I understand it
owned by the developer well up three has
been designated a two bit and property
but it remains the same dimensions as a
three-bedroom in order to ensure that
the 50/50 mix what three dimensions
should mirror those of plot for this is
the undertaking when the resulting
reduction in with one meter for the
combined plot three
four could be applied to the eastern
boundary giving sufficient space the
plant suitable height screening trees
this would give appropriate form of
privacy to my garden seating and
entertaining area it goes without saying
that suitable fencing and the soft
screening should be applied to the
entire site boundaries submission to
this is from Colleen Chris rag the
applicant good afternoon it's
application or for new homes is our
third third application on this site and
pretty misleading of ten flats and a
scheme of five during hours
I felt it necessary to say that in every
stage of this process a plant is
listening to the comments and concerns
raised by the neighbors the Town Council
a Planning Department and the committee
members at every stage a client is exit
Asif Li and amended the application
proposal so that a sensitive design
approach could be reached I believe that
most parties have concluded that the
current industrial use classes is
inappropriate on the site and not in
keeping with the primary residential
character the committee deemed the
previous application for five years
that's too much for the site and then a
modest scheme for four dwellings would
relate more program with the area and in
principle be acceptable this is a an
option that was backed by the Planning
Department during our pre-application
advice meeting ball advice that was
received during the pre-op meeting was
taken on board during the design process
during the course of this application we
have continued to respond in a way to to
the comments that have been received
this includes reducing the dwellings
dwelling sizes that were proposed
originally three times three bedroom and
one times two bedroom to now provide a
fair balance of mix of two and
three-bedroom units the planning officer
has been very professional and proactive
in assuring that a sensitive design is a
key now we read through the committee
reports you can see that the overriding
issues brought forward during the course
of
this application and that the previous
refusal have been taken on board moving
us with the support of the Planning
Department our client has invested a lot
of money into this application we have
been fair and professional in our
approach and we hope the committee can
agree with you the Planning Officers
recommendation thank you for listening
Jaron well the only officers like to
sign the move the recommendation No
thank you check Thank You chairman write
recommendation planning application 20
stroke
double-o 375 - full land riraf 148
Station Road Bernard be approved subject
since signing of a new rule undertaken
to confirm that developer will
contribute to SH coastal recreation
relational disturbance avoidance and
mitigation strategy our AMS and
conditions as detailed in section 8 of
the report and the members update if any
member wishes to second that emotion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone state your name now Thank You
chairman our second job proposal thank
you thank you very much to speak council
Erskine's and then cast a stamp please
yes hello three things to say really mr.
Johnson would you be so kind as to put
up the site plan again I just want to
show the shape of the road if I may now
all of you who are familiar with driving
into Burnham and I'm sure there's a fair
few of you here well know that as you
come down the road that passes the
library which is just to the top left of
this picture you have faced with a blind
Bend which can cause and has caused
certainly alarm
I'm not sure of any accidents yet so
that's fair enough
because there is the Tesco's entrance
there and that Tesco's entrance is very
busy
and of course there was also the
remembrance Avenue entrance which is in
the bottom-left of the of the picture
and then there's this new proposed busy
entrance on a blind Ben just beyond the
apex now I know that highways have not
don't think this is a problem but then
highways don't live here and I can tell
you that that is going to be a problem
with cars coming in and out immediately
after a blind Ben with a speed limit of
30 miles an hour which is sometimes
frankly exceeded and I think that's a
major issue and a reason for not having
so many houses there secondly I would
say the roof Heights mr. Johnson if you
could just quickly show that picture in
which you're showing the corresponding
roof Heights that would be useful thank
you
if you street seat really that that's
the one that went back one thank you now
to me those are big a bigger than the
surrounding buildings you have to go
some way to the left of that picture to
see something of a corresponding Heights
as far as I can see I have problems with
how large they are and thirdly and this
we've said so many times and I do not
understand why it doesn't carry small
weight Birnam on crouch is far beyond
the allocation of houses that was agreed
in the neighborhood plan now I
understand that mr. Lee will say yes but
that was just a minimum that is not how
it was read by the bernam electorate who
voted for a massive majority in favor of
the neighborhood plan in the referendum
and indeed even even so we've exceeded
it by so much that it's becoming
ridiculous we just simply cannot take
more houses in Burnham at this time
thank you
anybody else can sir Stan disaster speak
Thank You chairman and I put something
in the message back and we just have an
update of the number of approved
planning applications including the
strategic sites and which is normally
referred to as the five year
supply well it's the information
provided in the five-year Lance my exams
and the updated version can I have that
before I speak chairman please through
chairman I just don't have that
information to hand so so Thank You mr.
Lee I appreciate that so yet again we're
expected to approve a planning
application recommended by the officers
based on no evidence of the number of
houses that have already been approved
in Burnham I'll say what I normally say
mr. chairman there is a waiting list for
all the schools people who are moving
and find the properties in Burnham now
or having to have their children bussed
out to South Minster plume school
Southwood and Ferris these are family
houses you're building there I really
wouldn't have an issue chairman if they
were you know bungalows for people maybe
with mobility issues because it's right
in the center of the town you've got a
Tesco there you've got beautiful
facilities the family homes that we're
getting on all the surrounding areas
outside areas is burnup is massive I
can't remember the last count when I
actually did a house count count on the
number of applications so please forgive
me but I know what cats Erskine's has
said it's over and above if members are
minded to approve this there's a couple
of things I want to say is thank you
officers for recognizing condition 10
about the Japanese knotweed it is an
issue
I'd be very appreciative if that is
dealt with properly and it's the
objector said quite clearly is there a
possibility that he could have some
trees planting that will help protect
his privacy along the side I think
that's not too much to ask I totally
agree with counsel Erskine's that road
is absolutely a nightmare that turning
and I know somebody who lives opposite
and when I try and you know to even drop
them off you're taking your life into
your own hands down there and these
additional houses are going to produce
what how many cars at least four five
six cars it's just it's just too much
and cancer scans is speaking a great
deal of sense to me whether the offices
turn around and say for planning reasons
we cannot refuse this we do live here
and and also can I say
showing that Tesco's hasn't looked at
expanding and buying this bit of land
because the actual chaos their lorries
and they do stack down rent remembrance
Avenue when they're trying to get two or
three those great big antics in to
deliver to their site now I know you all
say they're not planning reasons but
this is actually what affects us here so
while you continuously keep developing
planning applications with more houses
above what we actually do need you need
to actually be taking that into account
as well thank you chairman Lucca would
like to come back on the point of
clarity thank you Tony
it's it's with regards to its regards to
this slide that's actually on the screen
at the moment there's there's some lines
and there's a narrative but I can't read
the narrative and I just wondered
perhaps if mr. Johnson could just tell
us what these lines are and the broken
lines and what they actually referred to
it looks to me it might be something to
do the previous application where you
had a quite the chimney but they've got
the bit behind it mr. Johnson could you
just explain what that is if I can try
and just zoom in on that just bear with
me a second please
right the top one is the approximate
bridge height of the character fluke
I'll probably have to get back to you
it's this it's slightly distorted from
what I can look at so if I could come
back to you on on that annotation well
chairman three years I think it's quite
important because we're trying to
understand how this fits within the
context to the other properties you know
my impression is one of the lines shows
you the the height of the house nearby
and it fits below that but I was just
curious chairman what these what these
other narratives were I guess one is to
do with the the chimneys of the previous
application which is slightly higher
than where yeah that's the bit yeah okay
so the first one is approximate Ridge
level it's even difficult for me - ah
right right
proximate Ridge level of buildings are
long something yes I think it's probably
easy yes that's right and the lower one
is ridge line of wick wall closed-shell
abundant Sun a bungalow on long yeah on
brick wall close yes okay
well I just add that Western Road is not
really relevant to this except that on
the far left a tall house shows a
Ridgeline that I don't even know if is
on Western Road but I suppose it could
be the point is is that there these are
big that's my point
anyway okay anybody else wish to speak
not at the moment chairman there was an
opportunity to come back on a couple of
points the office is a question and then
yes
yeah thank you Kevin I I just wanted to
ask a question at this stage that if
members were minded to approve this is
it possible too that we could include
some kind of screening because I think
we've all had some we've all had some
correspondents but from nearby neighbor
it's about overlooking although the
report does say that there is no
overlooking I just wondered if that
would be possible and not certainly
wouldn't yeah I can't Park it there
[Music]
sorry just wanted to come back on a
couple of points which probably include
that just in terms of highway safety and
the issues of the blind Bend and and
vehicles ingress and egress in I'll just
point out that Highway Safety was not a
reason for refusal on the previous
schemes it would be sorry the difficulty
obviously that we have there is that to
introduce a new reason for refusal on a
scheme which is notwithstanding the
numbers and and elements of layout is
not dissimilar from the previous review
scheme could put the council into a
difficult position and probably open
on the second reason for a height issue
was raised height of the buildings again
that was sort of just just discussed
well I would point out is that again
just going back to the describe back to
the the the street scene there is well
strictly speaking that the building
isn't higher than the previous scheme
but it's a much more compact and open
scheme as we can see it's got a less
formal scale of development there ignant
gaps through the through the design so
to to then sustain under the ambit of a
previous reason for refusal that the
scheme is higher when all the other
matters would be addressed would be a
difficult one for the council to sustain
in my opinion point three again I think
this was raised by when the council's
about the the nature of the development
I would again just point out the
previous inspector accepted the
principle of housing development on this
site this is a brownfield site it does
comply with the NPP F in that respect so
again that would be very difficult and
this sort of ties in also recounts the
stamps point it very difficult to
sustain a reason for refusal on the
basis that there are additional
dwellings proposed to the area through
this scheme Thank You chairman I'm sorry
the last point I'll just point out again
is regarding the trees I think we should
have a look at the at the layout if we
can see the sorry that's the previous
scheme just go back the other way if we
can see the layout there there would be
some difficulty in proposing any screed
tree screening to the western side we
can see it's only about one point four
distance the boundary there and and
similarly even to the eastern side the
area there wouldn't be sufficient for
trees that provide the screening of the
building as may be considered by members
I will just point out that there are no
windows in the flank elevation so in
terms of overlooking there was no
overlooking from this scheme Thank You
chairman chairman cancer caste Erskine's
would like to put forward a second
proposal and councillors to stamp has a
question okay yes I'd like to propose
that this development is rejected I
appreciate mr. Johnson's comments but
equally I think we you know with if it
comes to appeal if we have a decent
lawyer we could probably get this
through I know it's a risk but we are
miles over our allocation this is on a
dangerous blind Bend and the roof height
so an issue do I have a seconder our
second you countless games okay what did
you want to say thank you just a bit of
clarity from mr. Lee one of my normal
points and the previous that obviously
speaking which I don't know very well
the new gentleman Michael and said about
the application because of the previous
applications the highways wasn't an
issue and it wasn't debated or whatever
wasn't a reason for a refusal mr. Lee
always tells me that you have to take
each planning application in its own
right is that right mr. Lee or does that
not apply now because we've got planning
history that's been refused it's just a
point of clarity and I also like like to
second what cancer Fluker said and that
surely on the eastern side some trees
can go down there to actually help that
you kept trees at all in skinny with a
high bushy top that can actually give
the privacy from the objector who
actually is going to be affected by this
development so Thank You council Fuuka
it can be put as a condition Thank You
mr. Lee thank you planning law is clear
that application must be determined in
accordance with the development plan and
it's material considerations
indicate otherwise and each application
must be to terminate so merit but a
material consideration is planning
history of a site something that should
be given greater way is the material
situation when it's been to appeal and
as mr. Johnson highlighted an
application for ten units has previously
been dismissed appeal but at this time
neither the principal or Highway Safety
matters such as that were considered to
be an issue it would be dangerous for an
authority to try and introduce these
again his highways was looked at partly
at last time so to try and revisit
issues when inspector was bound than to
be acceptable either as a principle
point or actually where the highway
movement is likely to be less in this
instance than it would have been at ten
would be a very dangerous road to take I
would say for members and for the
council in any just emulation to the
point about screening on the eastern
side my person blood there may be some
harm to the applicant in their appeal to
the neighbor in their opinion I do not
consider and the officers don't local
planning authority it's such a degree
that it is you know is a demonstrable
and real harm and such condition I don't
think would meet the test in my advice
to members thank you cheering thank you
very much we now move to the
recommendation counts the felucca could
you take a vote please okay so this is
for the officers recommendation of the
turret and so if you can indicate for
against or abstain councillor Basinger
abstain Sabeel or castor boys gone oh
poor Costas Luca for helm so Paul
Oh Skeens
against understand against Thank You
members six for two against one
abstention
okay thank you that's Julie carried we
move on to now to item 8 2004 one five
house 17 Road Tillingham Essex found on
pages 79 to 88 in a moment I will ask
call on officers to print this out some
members are reminded it if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known
by using the chat function within this
meeting I will ring great will then come
to you in term please keep your points
clear and succulents that whatever it is
give up on that this clean please could
you present the report Thank You chair
plane permission is sought for the
construction of the first floor side
extension over an existing side
projection this the location plan
showing the location the site this is
the pros block plan the existing ground
floor plan existing first floor plan the
existing at second floor plan it's the
proposed ground floor plan its first
floor plan
boost second floor plan these existing
elevations and proposed elevations
existing and proposed roof plans this
application is a resubmission of
previously refused applications 1900 two
five six house and 1900 705 house as can
be seen from the elevation plans of
these previous applications the proposed
design has changed min minimally between
these two previous applications and the
application before us the applicant the
current application is therefore
recommended before refusal needs the
photographs of the site Thank You chair
thank you very much
I have one submission for mrs.
Christopher Collins the applicant dear
sir we write to you regarding the
ongoing planning application to extend
our home the reason behind our
application is to make the house grow
with our family so we can become a
long-term family home during the covert
19 lockdown we have worked in our garden
to plant and develop member groups to
help provide additional privacy for us
and their neighbors number two and
number four significant role the bamboo
is planted from the alleyway leading to
and from our front garden to the rear
garden and runs along the boundary h of
our property to the far end of the
garden in response to your reasons for
refusal we feel that the the planned
changes to our house would not create a
bigger structure than the house opposite
us which has been under construction for
the past year and a half another another
third of the property has been added in
width and a loft room rather than a loft
space
has been built we have also been told by
neighbors that number 19 Brook Road they
previously held had a planning
application granted to knock down a
single story extension and built another
house in its place if this was to go
ahead we will become a row of three
houses and the bulk would become the
same as what we are hoping to build we
understand that this blend the
application has now expired and we are
concerned that they may have mission to
grant permission to grantee in the
future regards mr. and mrs. Collins but
I officers would you like to say
anything before I move to the
recommendation Thank You chair
recommendation this planning application
20 double-o 415 stroke house 17 Brooke
Road sending a mess he refused for the
reasons detailed in section 8 of this
report if ending member wishes to second
that motion please turn on your video
I meant your microphone and state your
name now right it's there any speakers
please yes chairman cast of Luke would
like to speak Thank You chairman okay so
what we feeling is here chairman Issa is
a young family there were local family
and they are an expanding family and
they basically run out of space chairman
in lived in their house it's quite
interesting chairman if the members turn
to page 90 of the LDP and in particular
policy 5.3 it says alterations
extensions or additions are important
ways to existing building stock to adapt
to the changing needs of a household and
it goes it goes on from there so what
they actually want to do chairman
accords with policy five point two eight
so that then leaves us with the old
conundrum of policy d1 what does it look
like now this is a very wide plot I know
this plot well it's a very well I plot
chairman my view is is
that the design is fine for the location
and that the principle the development
accords with the ODP and German we've
had similar applicants like this
applications like this in Orchard Road
South Minister where you've got
semi-detached houses and people built
over their garages and everything else
and I know that every single application
has to be dealt on its own no it's but I
do think German the policy five point
two eight certainly allows for this to
happen so really Germany is its two
places what does it look like and there
are no objections I don't think chairman
for neighbors which is very very
important and I and I note the the
comment from King and parish council and
I know that the location is well-known
because I think the clock may live along
there somewhere but at the end of the
day chairman in my mind this does look
okay and therefore it does accord with
policy d1 and I'd propose to him and
that contrary to the officers
recommendation we approve this and I
know it's not a planning condition but
if we do approve it chairman and we do
say that it comes with policy d1 it
allows for a young family to stay in the
village and that's the future of the
village chairman thank you I'll second
cancel Fluker cancer stamp we have to
support local people in our communities
chairman thank you come back chairman on
that point yes to things or to start
with two things firstly I just obviously
counts of Lucas highlighted paragraph
five point two point eight the LDP and
he read out the first line that
paragraph and I read out the second line
a well-designed extension to the div so
it's on a been dots made that again a
well-designed extension development can
complement and even enhance an existing
property and its its surrounding where
and its surroundings way whereas a
poorly designed scheme can have a
significant detrimental impact on the
original character the streets a
basically what that policy is saying or
that point is saying is that as a
principle there is no objection to
extending
and it comes down to design that is what
that officers report says it clearly
explains that we don't have a principle
against extending the dwelling so I
think that paragraph read in its
entirety is a moot point and offers very
little to the termination this
application all I would say is that
planning legislation is quite clear
their personal circumstances of an
applicant should only be taking to
consideration if they are very special
the consideration of somebody needing
larger space to accommodate their family
would not be very special circumstances
and hoping or aspiring to retain
existing families within the village is
also something that should not really be
a material situation above and beyond
the policy allocation of increasing
properties and such an approach has been
found to be unlawful so I'd be very
conscious of members giving any real
weight to that as determination at this
application the objection is from the
office as relates to design it turns in
it isn't a subjective matter which is
obviously something we've often discuss
and my advice for members would be to
look at this application as a simple
matter of does the development accord
with the council's adopted policies in
relation to design does the proposed
development have a detrimental impact on
the design the various points that
counts the flucos ways I think should
not really be given any demand for white
in the termination his application as it
wouldn't cord with planning law Thank
You chairman any moments wish to speak
German Casa Luker would like to come
back thank you very much I agree mr. Lee
I mean I was just trying to put some
meat on the bone so you know the
principles of the application I know
they're not planning reasons but I mean
mr. Lee speaks to design and if I could
just direct members to paragraph 7.2 I
mean this is in either in or just
adjacent to the conservation area or
telling them which is a very important
area and the conservation officer has no
problems with the design impacting on
the conservation area or otherwise so
Kim and I I really am confused and I
think from a subjective point
and it is very subjective this we know I
think it works and and and I've not
heard anything that has changed my mind
chairman Thank You anyone else wants to
speak German I just wanted to just
following on from my colleague mr.
Mittal II if the presentation can show
the site plan additional concern which
would support the reason for refusal in
terms of the impact of the development
on the character and appearance of the
area is the proximity of the extension
to the boundary with the adjoining
property to its to it to it to its east
it would present a significant and a
fairly monolithic flank elevation barely
a meter or so from the boundary while
not explicitly within the reasons for a
few so this part of the concern offices
has raised in terms of the impacts on it
when its overall character the extension
it would effectively double the size
practically of the building this is a
third application previous schemes are
refused for more or less the same reason
the amendments this scheme are were not
considered material and again as as mr.
Lee pointed out we support side
extensions where appropriate and
proportionate thank you chairman thank
you very much anyone else were to speak
no Chairman thank you
the proposal made by councillor Fokker
to concrete it offers recommendation to
approve this application seconded by
Councillor stamped couldn't do the count
please thank you and I will call members
in alphabetical order for against
abstain councillor passenger I'm sorry
I'm kind of confused about what we're
actually voting on here now is it to
approve country to the office respect
datian I approve sorry yes I approve
castle Beal for as the boys abstain and
castle chan has left the meeting members
council Fluker approve
please approve the schemes approve
[Music]
lovely thank you that's seven for German
one abstention
thank you very much let's do be
character proof can I have reasons for
approval please cabinet that we feel as
though it does are called with policy be
one that the design scale and bulk is
acceptable for its location thank you
for your conditions yes it's just that
the conditions are Malaysian to time
plans to take the got the plans in front
we know we would have them on the screen
and just don't know if the officer
Michael Johnson have got any suggested
conditions either sorry I would I would
in addition to what mr. Lewis suggested
I would also given the proximity of the
flank war to the boundaries to the
property to the east that any openings
in the flank elevation be the subject of
any future planning applications now
although a for example an opening can be
put at first floor level but would have
to be obscured we wouldn't want the
perception of overlooking so any
openings would be there for control
permitted development why should be
removed in that respect everybody happy
with that greed move on to plan the
application 2005 o to house and 20
double O 5 o 3 lb see the wheat but upon
Keeling's killings road ng found on
pages 89 to 98 in a moment I will call
on the officer to present this ayats and
members a reminder that if you wish to
chat on this item please make this known
by using the check front chat function
within this meeting I will then come to
you in turn please keep your points
clear and precise then we got mrs. miss
keen represent it yes we have Thank You
chair he has Thank You householder and
listed building consent is sought for
the construction of a lean-to storage
building for storage of looks household
and garden equipment I have a verbal
update as a letter of support has been
received for this application commenting
on developments being an asset to the
dwelling and in keeping with the
surrounding area this is the location
plan plan the existing floor plan
proposed floor plan existing elevations
elevations
and photos of the sights Thank You chair
Oh
this application is recommended for
approval thank you under the Platte
Council of public participation scheme
we have received two submissions welcome
objector and one from the agent in line
with public participation scheme I have
reviewed the submissions and will now
read them out allocating two minutes
only for the reading of each submission
in accordance with the scheme submission
one is from andrew.snowdon predictor an
addition to the comments submitted
objecting to the application I would
like to stress the roof material
composed is a modern material totally
out of keeping with all other buildings
on the site for every it's very clear
from publicity publicly available
satellite imagery and within the
boundary of the property previous
planned state the distance from the
existing building to the boundary as 3.1
proposed building is 2.9 meters plus 1/2
the boundary this would effectively put
the new building on top of the P ro W
number 10 which it should be noted the
applicant has blocked for many months
long before Cove at 19 this has been
reported to an acknowledged biases
county highway county council the
application has sought to move the
boundary to the domestic of the domestic
property outwards into april and without
proper process this application should
be given their status is very well aware
of the planning process
I strongly oppose the application
submission to from TC Matthews TMI a
chartered surveyor at the agent 20mm 502
house and 2005 303 LBC the Bo's leads
our story building week you bomb the
application is for modest lean-to style
story building attached to existing cart
Lodge for the storage of logs and other
household and garden equipment for the
two dwellings on the site the wheat bar
and annex the simple storage building
will be constructed along with a
their war of the existing cockroach
using an existing repaired concrete slab
which has been put in place along with
the rear wall for many years original
doorway the cartridge will be reopened
to provide access the attached
photographs demonstrate that the
concrete slab and the doorway have been
placed since the property was that have
been in place since the property was
purchased and not that the excess
doorway is not recent the materials
proposed have been carefully selected to
be in keeping with the other buildings
on the site and the conservation area
officer in his response has confirmed
that the selected materials are entirely
appropriate to the location hang on a
minute let's confirm that the result
it's a modest and sympathetic additional
52.9 why building will be wholly within
the existing residential kurtik as
showing the appropriate documents the
building is not encroached on on to the
applicants FL but will lie wholly within
the existing residential cottage the
application is supported by the parish
council Conservation Area and its
officers recommendation approval since
its calm design does not harm the
appearance and character of the area or
the listed building we therefore ask
that the committee follow the
recommendation for its officers and
approve these applications does the only
officer want to say anything before I
move the recommendation no thank you
Karen
thank you very much the recommendation
is that planning application 20050 to
house the wheat barn
Kili Road Benji Essex be approved
subjects
and that application 2005 oh three LBC
four listed building consent be granted
subject that the pictures are detailed
in Section eight of the report if any
member wishes to second that motion
please turn on your video and move your
microphone and state your name now thank
you
any member yeah I'll second it thank you
against the boys members who would like
to speak first classist and would like
to speak please chairman just a couple
of little points I'm just looking at the
history of the planning applications
that been approved
how many garden stores does one person
need because if you look at the history
I think he's got about three up there so
I've got a huge garden that's just a
point of accuracy and about the pro2
is it not is this anything to do this
application can mr. Lee help because
it's really important we help support
public rights of ways for people to be
able to get access to our beautiful
countryside Thank You chairman mr. Lee
I'll pass you over to the office on the
public right-of-way issues its
application in relation to how many
garden buildings does someone need to
sense that softly a personal permission
what the need is to see is whether
there's a level of harm from it the
application as it has been made so it's
not trying to be argued that it's commit
development that's incidental so this
becomes a consideration if you consider
that there's a proliferation of
outfielders that you Chechen the
character the area then that would be an
issue but there is no policy that would
go against the principle of having
multiple outbuilding thank Jim thank you
okay can I just add to that I'm just
looking at the history and while I've
not had to been if you have gone into
the file itself again we can see that
you know we have a number of full
applications and listed building
applications some of them appear quite
similar so we may actually be sometimes
dealing with the same buildings so it's
not obvious in a case like this that it
means that there are X number of
buildings being being proposed but we
could look up on the site history and if
members feel we can combat on that but
it's not a foregone conclusion that
necessarily means that there are
you know several store buildings within
the site Thank You chairman yes the
prowl runs adjacent to the red line
boundary shown on the location plan and
the block plan so it would appear that
the the development wouldn't impact on
the prowl thank you thank you
not really now you can have one of the
triggers for being permitted development
is 50% of the garden it can't go over
that but it's a multi-layered assessment
so that's one of them but you wouldn't
be able to automatically just do 50 buck
that is one of the considerations yes I
think that's how it's gone under the
current page there are no but no other
members wishing to speak German we've
got a second webcast a boy second that's
right 2005 Oh to house the wheat bran
Ealing Road dingy be approved subject
conditions are detailed in section 8 of
the report and that application 20mm 503
LBC for listing building consent be
granted service conditions as detailed
in section 8 of the report burner can
you take the vote please Thank You
chairman I will call everybody in
alphabetical order for against abstain
counsel the passenger approve he'll
approve voice
well caster helm or caster hull caster
hollow thank you that's all thank you
skip cast Erskine's for class the stamp
Oh
Thank You members that seven for no
abstentions none against thank carried
thank you very much burner we moved to a
giant again to rising ten tree
protection order 20 below 463 WT p o
land north west of river lee mitchell
chase mainland essex found on pages 99
204 in a moment I'll ask the officer to
present this islets and members a
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item please make this known by
using the check function within the
meeting I will then come to you in turn
please keep your points clear except
where it's good to chairman can you just
pause for a second while I call Cass
DeLuca back in yes thank you very much
thank you very much thank you German we
moved twice of 10 tree preservation
order 2004 63 WCPO land northwest of
River Lee Michels Chase mainland found
on page 99 204 in a moment I will call
the officers to present this item
members a reminder if you wish to speak
on this item please make it known using
the chat function within the meeting I
will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succulent
miss Keene please report please Thank
You chair permission is sought for the
removal of a section of prune Espinosa
from the woodland measuring 3.5 meters
in length and 1 meter in width
the trees are subject to the woodland
preservation order TPO 418 it's the
location plan showing their area in
which the trees would be removed from
this shows the proposed works which
would allow for a path to be created and
these are pictures of the trees to be
removed from the woodland the
application is recommended for approval
Thank You chair thank you very much
I move to the recommendation for
approval if any member wishes to second
that motion please turn on your video I
moved your microphone and state your
name now please any members councillor
Fluke are supportive okay that's duly
seconded I now invite members to make
any comments on this report please Donna
can you indicate who wants to speak yeah
we'd nobody wishing to speak on this one
thank you
we'll move straight the recommendation
garner can you take the count please
Thank You chairman
so again it's four against abstain
counselor passenger hello Casa Beall or
Thank You Cass counselor boys
Luca for ham for how's the hull Casa de
hull is that forward thank you very much
Castle for Stamp
so that's a poor none against no
abstentions that's carried thank you
chairman thank you very much so I
counselor help chairman can't step in a
second I've just realized that members
when we members look to approve the
flats at South Minster there was no
conditions imposed recommended and at
the moment and if we left I think just
in reality we'd be officers would be
bringing it back next committee with a
set of suggested condition so just
wondering if members were happy to
revisit that this moment and to delegate
the conditions to officers over chairman
yeah in check and through Chairman I
would chairman bair demand I made
proposal on this yeah a bearing in mind
the muddle that we got in elsewhere with
a public house in Morden I think
chairman that would be very wise
chairman during those deliberations can
you please ensure that you consult with
the conservation officer to make sure
that he's happy with materials thank you
okay that's fine everyone else happy
agreed
greed okay right any other word since
the business the chairman of the
committee decides the urgent there are
none closer to the meeting members thank
you for your contribution this afternoon
Thank You officers and thank you to
Berlin for organizing a listen get it
all smoothly run through with no
interruptions no problems when I closed
the meeting at 1449 thank you all
you